nos preguntan cuál es el valor del
término 100 de esta sucesión el primer
término es 15 siguen 93 y menos 3 mejor
hagamos una tabla
tengo el término por aquí y por acá voy
a poner el valor el valor del término el
primer término ya dijimos es 15 el
segundo es 9 el tercero es 3 solo estoy
copiando la información para estar
seguros de que asociamos el término con
su valor indicado el cuarto término es
menos 3 y nos preguntan cuál es el valor
del término 100 de esta sucesión bueno
veamos qué pasa aquí intentemos
encontrar un patrón pensemos un poco que
está pasando del primer término al
segundo término 15 para 9 bueno parece
que disminuimos 6
siempre es bueno pensar en cuanto
cambian los números como primera opción
porque este es el patrón más simple
entonces bajamos 6 unidades y restamos 6
unidades y de 9 a 3
también restamos 6 unidades y de tres a
menos tres de nuevo restamos seis
unidades así que parece que cada término
lo obtiene restando 6 de la anterior el
segundo término es 6 unidades menor que
el primero el tercero es 12 unidades
menor que el primero o restarle al
primero 2 veces 6 el cuarto término es
restarle al primero tres veces 6 y así
sucesivamente por lo tanto si buscas un
término encontrará su valor tomando el
primero y restándole una vez menos que
el número del término por 6 piénselo así
al primer término 15 no le quitamos nada
o de hecho otra manera le restamos 6
0 veces es decir 15 menos 0 por 6 así
encontramos el primero cómo fue que
encontramos al segundo bueno tenemos al
15 y le quitamos una vez 6 o podemos
decir 15 menos 1 por 6 o también lo
podemos ver como 15 más 1 por menos 6 de
cualquier manera encontramos el valor
restándole a 15
una vez 6 como encontramos al tercero
bueno tenemos al 15 y le quitamos dos
veces 6 o podemos decir 15 menos 2 por 6
encontramos el valor restándole al 15 2
veces 6 como encontramos al cuarto bueno
tenemos el 15 y le quitamos 3 veces 6 o
podemos decir 15 menos 3 por 6 ahora
bien si ves el patrón aquí para
encontrar el valor del cuarto término
tenemos que poner el número del término
menos 1 aquí para el cuarto término
obtendremos un 3 para el tercero tenemos
un 2 para el segundo obtenemos un
para el primero tenemos un cero por lo
tanto para encontrar el valor del
enésimo término tendremos que tomar al
15 y quitarle y se observa con cuidado
tenemos el valor en el -1 aquí cuando en
es igual a 4 n
los tres cuando en estrés n uno es 2
cuando en estos en el -1 es uno cuando
en ese uno en el -1 es cero entonces el
valor serán 15 - n 1 x 6
por lo tanto si queremos encontrar el
término 100 podemos encontrar su valor
observando este patrón o escribiéndolo
así el término 100 de nuestra secuencia
será quien bueno serán 15 menos 100
menos 1 lo cual es 99
esto por 6 cierto suelo he seguido el
patrón para 1 tenemos 10 parados tenemos
un 1 aquí para 3 tenemos 12 aquí para
100 tenemos un 99 aquí así que
calculamos cuánto es esto cuánto es 99
por 6 de hecho esto lo puedes hacer
mentalmente esto será lo mismo que en
600 menos 6 6% de 600 menos 6 594 pero
si no quieres hacerlo de esta manera
podemos hacerlo de la forma tradicional
6 por 9 54 ponemos el 4 y llevamos 5 6
por 9 54 559 594
entonces esto de aquí es 594 y queremos
saber cuánto es
15 - 594 a veces esto es un poco confuso
pero la forma en la que siempre resuelvo
esto en mi cabeza es la siguiente es
pensar que esto es exactamente lo mismo
que el negativo de 594 menos 15 y si no
me crees distribuye este signo menos 1
por 594 es menos 594 menos 1 por menos
15 m es 15 así que estas dos expresiones
son equivalentes aunque la segunda me
parece mucho más fácil de entender
cuánto es 594 menos 15 bueno eso lo
podemos ser mentalmente 594 menos 14 m
es 580 menos 1 579 y después tengo este
signo negativo
así que obtengo menos 579 y ya podemos
concluir que el término 100 de nuestra
sucesión será menos 570
y ya hemos terminado nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo